معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس انطلاقا من هذه المعطيات التي
قدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي عن عملياته في
القطاع ماذا في اخر التطورات والبيانات
العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المعركه على اشدها حقيقه وهي
تدور الان على نحو كثيف في منطقه جحر
الديك والمغر في المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه
غزه وواضح بانه هنالك اشتباكات عنيفه
حقيقه بالرشاشات من العيار
الثقيل نستطيع حتى ان نسمعها من هنا من
منطقه غلاف غزه لا ادري ان كنتم تسمعون
ذلك لكن واضح بان هذه الاشتباكات العنيفه
ما زالت مستمره منذ ساعات حقيقه وواضح بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يستخدم في منطقه معينه
في تلك المنطقه اي ال القنابل المضيئه
وهذا ربما يكون مؤشرا الى ان حدث ما يجري
على الارض هناك يبدو ان اشتباكا كبيرا
وجها لوجه يدور الان ما بين قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمقاومه الفلسطينيه ربما
تكون هنالك محاوله للاشاره من خلال هذه
القنابل المضيئه للقوات الاسرائيليه
للتقدم او للتراجع او للاشاره الى قوات
الاسناد حول وجود جرحى او مصابين في هذه
العمليه من اجل التقدم نحو اجلائهم من ارض
المعركه لكن واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يستخدم منذ نحو ساعه على الاقل هذه
القنابل المضيئه في منطقه جحر الديك
للاشاره الى منطقه بعينها تشهد كما يبدو
اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
التي نستطيع ان نسمعها حتى من هنا من غلاف
غزه وهي مستمره حتى هذه الدقائق منطقه جحر
الديك كانت تشهد في الايام الماضيه على
الاقل في ال8 ساعه الماضيه اشتباكات عنيفه
نحن نشاهد الان قنبله اضاءه جديده تطلق
ربما تشاهدونها الان عبر
العدسه وعبر الشاشه وبالفعل هذه قنبله
مضيئه اخرى في نفس الموقع تقريبا في منطقه
جحر الديك
اي تحاول كما يبدو القوات الاسرائيليه
هناك الاشاره الى مكان
وجودها وهنالك ايضا طائره استطلاع يبدو
انها ستدخل على خط هذه المواجهه وهي تحوم
في اجواء المنطقه التي تشهد هذه
الاشتباكات اذا نحن امام تطور هنا في
منطقه جحر الديك على الاقل في الساعه
الاخيره وهي هذه الاشتباكات المحتدم التي
يستخدم فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي المدفعيه الثقيله في ضرب بعض
المواقع لكن هو يمتنع حتى الان عن ضرب هذه
المنطقه التي كنت اشير اليها بالتحديد
والتي يحاول الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما
الاشاره الى مكانه ومكان وجوده فيها من
خلال القنابل ال المضيئه اذا هنالك
طائره استطلاع طائره استطلاع تدخل على
اجواء المنطقه تحديدا هي الان تحاول ربما
ان تخترق اجواء قطاع غزه السياج الامني
وربما ستدخل الى المنطقه التي تشهد هذه
العمليات ال البريه والعمليات المسلحه
هناك واضح بان هنالك قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه
في مازق ما او هي تخو اشتباكا عنيفا مع
المقاومه الفلس فلينيه وهذه المنطقه كما
كنت اقول منذ يومين تشهد بالفعل غارات
جويه عنيفه و قصف مدفعي يكاد لا يتوقف في
اطار عمليات التوغل ومحاوله السيطره من
جانب القوات الاسرائيليه على منطقتي جحر
الديك والمغر الواقعتين في المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه عدا عن ذلك من هذه
المنطقه ايضا بدات القوات الاسرائيليه
قوات الفرقه 36 المناوره والتقدم نحو
مخيمات المنطقه الوسطى ل مدينه لقطاع غزه
وتحديدا في منطقه البريج الذي اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بشكل رسمي يوم امس بانه بدا
هجوما في تلك المخيمات وبدا تحديدا من
مخيم البريج عمليه عسكريه ايه واسعه
بالاشاره الى باقي المناطق المناطق في كل
شمال قطاع غزه ما زالت مشتعله نحن نرى صحب
الدخان التي ما زالت تتصاعد من المنطقه
الشماليه ايضا
لمدينه غزه حيث حيي الدرج والتفاح